to help stop would-be pirates from
heading out to sea
the european union is training coast
guard police
and justice officials the safest place
to do that right now
is off the coast of somalia
with the opportunity and the offer from
atalanta
to to to use the vessel you and david as
a floating classroom
it's for us an excellent opportunity to
combine theoretical lessons
with the maritime lessons and practical
sessions here on both of the ships
foreign
we have to train somali people that for
the time being the security in somalia
is not for us as we wanted that could
endanger
the people we are training and that's of
course not the objective we have now the
possibility
to do that onward of ships of eu enough
work
excellent cooperation it's not easy
think about
all the affairs you have to arrange for
people on board on board with local
authorities
but we have also seen that we can
overcome those problems and actually
this is again an excellent start for
something which will make
a difference in how we approach somalia
and how we are
assisting them to develop their own
maritime security strategy
taking part in this exercise are
somalia's chief justice
and the presidents of the appeals court
regional courts and military tribunals
the idea is to demonstrate european
techniques for gathering
evidence from suspected pirates
judges are not just learning new methods
they also gain an understanding of how
evidence that could influence trials in
their very own courts
is collected